deve vedere essere un nuovissimo video
io sono paesi oggi sono composte fondo
nazionale per giocare a rocket league
lenny dei maya e camille e sembra non è
cani non c'entra niente però lo teniamo
la mamma mia la partenza è buona
sempre fermava piantino ok va bene
bello bello bello ok siamo conto degli
esseri umani questo è già un buon punto
sì questo è vero bello ma sì ma si tanto
ormai lo accompagnano anche dentro
canile non l'ha sbloccata canino capito
che ha fatto quello in parte forse gol
di si chiamano legni de dalmata in una
lingua strana e cahill
quindi c'e qualcosa di strano dunque
dopo il song si tradurrà per il vero non
l'ho capito niente ma che è il prodotto
non lo fa lo sapevo da sta accadendo a
centrocampo e si va beh certo ovviamente
mi sembra così ovvia è ovvio il tuo
logico tito normale turbo eccolo va bene
ci recuperiamo con quel tiro ciofeca che
era successo facciamo come come quei
terribili questa è la partita ma sì
abbiamo fatto tre gol per ora normale
che io sì sì niente ma allora guarda
arrivare mobile guerra cine mobile
perché sul palo bright eyes lavorato non
vale aspettavo tutti va dai dai dai
era una roba è certo di un bravissimo
golf si prendera mai a prendi
chiaramente ma è stato anche quando farà
la più veloce di me ma guarda io l'ho
provata a seguire arrivo abbiamo se ci
arrivò prima io non avevano mai prima io
ti prego parla
modo stavo per far parlare che l'aveva
anche tolta del cipe davvero pure gara
non so come ho fatto a toglierla era
bello infatti barra è sì quasi separava
anche la seconda mache foto ch mille
ovviamente 1900 non l'ho toccata per
quale teoria logica ok
bello bello belli sia bellissimo
benissimo allora grazioli sembriamo di
nuovo tornati in platino ma giuro che
stiamo sembriamo che sì sì esatto
sembriamo di platino ma vinciamo 3
chiamato il mito che sono la gara un
platino non sono anche loro sì sì certo
guarda questa roba bravissimo ma sei
falso che costa uscendo anche per avere
era veramente bene vorrei c'è e manca
niente da gol
troppa roba pazzesca e si abbassava
toccarlo poteva parlare mezzo dico bravo
ora io vi giuro io vi giuro io mi auguro
che io ho schiacciato la il tasto a del
joystick lo schiacciato una volta come
per un aspetto che tanto non tediare
forse addirittura bellissimo respinge ma
ci sono io vabbè cosa succede cosa
succede di socio mi dissocio me va bene
ok è un po corta anche un capo ma ma
l'attentato un controllo in posizione
rischiosissima e io l'ho punito per
questo che bellissima brutto brutto
proprio prove d'avola syrah che poi cosa
potrebbe essere un tir interessante era
e lo è
porca barca il favi ora 22 youtuber che
perde pertanto i due dottori non si può
avere
non si può vedere lo spot i tories e
spagnolo
i magi coste mike a lui era pronto qui è
il maggior spagnolo bel gol
vabbè bravo mai cosa da fare questa cosa
non vada vada vada vada tutto quello che
voi ragazzi non sono che avevo fatto
quindi vede che mi caso però va bene
quello si è dimenticato come si para
bene comitato le faccio ste cose non si
sa cosa è un po più spesso interventi di
più è che cosa siamo certi che aspetta
che tilt a ma per chi è anche buono sai
sono un video e cambio profondo effetto
benissimo vada vada sì sì sì sì sì sì
beh forse lo è anche pericolosissimo
esatto va bene povere si greve ragazzi
ma che ti come già chi abbia preso
quella roba incredibile più palo dopo ed
è però che se lo prende ma qual è la
posso giocare io a questo gioco non ci
posso giocare io non ce ne aspettiamo le
sei perse erano così si penserà forse
puoi dire no forse poi di rino ragazzina
va bene se vi dica accompagna la parte
nella palla nella nostra porta via una
bottiglia ragazzi non si è mai vista una
cosa del genere non si è mai vista ma
cos'è io penso due par tre pali c'è
niente ma interni madaio veramente non
ho parole
no mi ha lasciato mia la caravan pato
nella chiamata una botta riina di
tremenda e mi stava chiamando mannaggia
non ora mi ha dato variazione della
terza prova ancora a posto
[Musica]
bravo troppo secondi posti ma io non ho
turbo non posso fare niente solo l'audio
è 6 1 contro 1 st piangente dentro così
noi vinciamo questa dai forti fa abbiamo
fatto 8 milioni di palin è possibile che
si perde la quale lascia laila
continuiamo così guarda barra ferma
immobile
mamma mia sono creduto tensione il
contrasto vinto io
allora io il turbo che volevo e va bene
bravo dove pato la palla in mezzo è un
ottimo controllo suo ma che l'ho tolto
lo so come ma poi la quale arrivato là
dove la dove è arrivato quello che i
laghi non solo minipala gare ma quando
colpiscono indietreggio io non so come
mezzi arcana ma come ho fatto
guarda come sono andati entrambi ad
incrocio barba mia ragazzi mamma mia e
si vince anche così ogni tanto che
bisogna arrivare ora è così si giocava
così si vince
mi sia piaciuto questo era l'episodio
con stefan e sui rockets league si vede
scritto anche il suo canale per tizio
italiano che non mi piace anche ai
socialmente da studiare sotto il
fischione come sempre ci vediamo
[Musica]